[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Carolyn J Dean who is the Charles J
style professor of history and French at
Yale she is a historian of modern Europe
with a focus on the 20th century whose
work explores the intersection of ideas
and culture most recently in the context
of genocide professor Dean is the author
of several books that focus on the
historical and cultural representation
of victims most recently a version and
erasure the fate of the victim after the
Holocaust and the fragility of empathy
after the Holocaust
she is also written extensively about
gender and sexuality and France and on
the intellectual history of French
theory today we'll talk with Professor
Dean about her latest book the moral
witness trials and testimony after
genocide welcome professor Dean thank
you let's start with an overview of your
book tell us about it
well it was an attempt to try to
understand the cultural meaning of
genocide when we think about genocide we
think about the legal meaning right the
legal meaning which was penned by the
Polish Jewish lawyer Raphael Lemkin in
1943 he he lost members of his own
family and he was in the United States
and he and he developed as Neela jism
this term too to describe the specific
crimes committed by the Nazis against
the Jews meaning the destruction the
attempted destruction of an entire
people as well as their culture which
and that that was not a crime that had a
name wasn't that it hadn't happened but
it didn't have a name and I was really
interested not so much in the in the
legal history of genocide since 1948
really but in how we came to think about
it as a crime what kind of crime was it
what did people experience that that
distinguish genocide from
a war right and the killing that goes on
in a war okay so what I know you have
done a lot of work on the Holocaust for
this book what led you to write it and
you know what genocides are you looking
at I'm mainly looking at the Holocaust
as a B and I'm interested in how it
became a model kind of for other
genocides in the West now it doesn't
mean I'm not interested in saying it
should be or shouldn't be I'm just
saying it is and we should explore how
it came to be so that now there is in
the scholarly world there's a discussion
about the Holocaust is something that's
been Americanized globalized package and
people that argue that or thinking about
Schindler's List movies that that
discuss the Holocaust the kind of way
Hollywood has taken up the Holocaust
there were miniseries about the
Holocaust so it's become I mean people
have talked about it have talked about
it since the 1980s as a it's become
overly commercialized as an event
whether that's true or not I'm not
interested in that so much as I am in
how it became a if it's a global
discourse what does that mean that it's
global if that makes sense
sure so how did you do the research for
the book well I I worked in French
libraries I I was I covered a lot of
different attitudes toward the Holocaust
on the part of different kinds of people
that is I tried to figure out how its
meaning changed over time and so I was
worked in France in Germany and I worked
in in Italy a little bit and and and
then there were there was a lot of stuff
in the United States as well yeah okay
so in looking at the timeline of the
term genocide before the term was
actually created up until today how has
it changed over time and what are some
of the things that you looked at to
determine that well the most important
thing I suppose it was coined as I said
in 1943 it was it became part of what
was called the Convention on genocide in
1948 signed by many Western countries
and others but it wasn't a term in
general use at all until the late 60s
and 70s and even then so I think that
it's important to remember
that there were there I think two phases
an understanding or three phases and
understanding genocide one is the memory
of the concentration camps after World
War two which essentially was the
concentration camps were envisioned as
labour camps in which many people died
and then after 1961 and the trial of
Arafah shman the Nazi Minister for
transport in Jerusalem the his trial
really created this image of the
survivors and and brought attention to
the fact that millions of Jews died now
it's hard for us to imagine but actually
until the late 67 and 70s people did not
think of the Holocaust as a crime
against Jews it was considered as it to
be a crime against humanity and and its
victims were political resistance and
civilians and and others but not Jews in
particular and after the sixties the so
if the extermination camps which were
known about obviously we're seen as just
sort of an extension of labor camps
right they were seen as one extreme and
extreme version of a labor camp by the
1980s death camps and concentration
camps were seen as completely different
things because death camps were where
Jews were sent and labor camps were
where others were sent Jews - okay and
then the title of your book moral
witness let's talk about that term and
what you mean by that well the witness
the witness as people may know is a
biblical term obviously it it comes from
the Bible as I said and in fact in the
Holocaust Memorial Museum the it's
etched on though on the entry you are my
witnesses and so what I was interested
in is how this term which has been used
by abolitionist movements it's used by
evangelicals you know in its religious
sense and it's used by secular political
movements and now people use it all the
time to say bearing witness to talk
about our response to crimes how we are
morally responsible for seeing
testifying reporting etc
that we can presumably use this
testimony to stop genocide in the future
to stop these kinds of crimes okay and
how how do we imagine victims of
genocide today very differently so the
after 1961 in the Eichmann trial in
Jerusalem we imagine III think the
cultural imagination of the witness to
genocide is a Holocaust survivor whose
image was if you think of Elie Wiesel I
don't know the Nobel prize-winner yeah
he well it's kind of a wizened weary
wise person and this is not true it's
just this is the image we have and and
this came from the trial and the image
of these people who had suffered you
know unfathomable violence and these
people were had a certain kind of quiet
dignity and they were considered to have
developed wisdom from their experience
and now with the proliferation of
genocide we what we see is a very
different image of people who are sort
of completely downtrodden to be pitied
victims who we must save I think it's a
very different image and and that that
has changed with the proliferation as I
said in genocide yeah okay and then so
what are you hoping your readers take
away from your book mm-hmm I guess I I
would like people to think about how
things we take for granted the word
genocide the events of genocide are
actually very complicated historical
creations they don't just come out of
note they're not just self-evident
things that we point to and say oh you
know this is a genocide words have to be
coined experiences have to be imagined
and understood in certain ways and they
can change over time so genocide means
something very different even if it has
one definition it means different things
culturally and that will change again in
the future
okay so what are your next steps what
are you working on now oh now I'm
working on a book about bystanders and
what does that mean that means that
means that the category usually people a
very famous historian coined the word
bystander to talk about victims
perpetrators and by Stan
the three categories that we need to
explore in order to understand mass
violence and the bystander is the most
difficult because it's clear who victims
are it's clear who perpetrators are and
then there are the rest of us right who
can be by our inaction are we
perpetrators by our wetters our moral
responsibility to do something the kind
of judgment of bystanders has always
been very complicated and and I think
that and it's a term that only really
our moral obligation to do something
it's a self very recent the idea that we
shouldn't speak up etc so I think that
so I'm very interested in historically
how this experience of by standards is
actually lived
what is the lived experience of people
in McCann occupied France in particular
France under the Nazis from the
perspective of victims so that must be
somewhat difficult to get at from a
research perspective so how are you
doing that I'm looking at all the
testimonies of we have the fortune of
archive here which is the archive for
which was started here to take
testimonies from survivors and so we
have just a wealth of information here
and I also am looking at I've been
working in Paris at the Shoah the
memorial of the shore where they hold
archives of occupied France and and the
kinds of victims and their experiences
you can go through these and there's a
terrific amount of material especially
on Jewish resistance I'm particularly
interested in people who were hidden or
people who were Jewish themselves but
and hatton but were in hiding so they
had to manage their identities so just
and you could so if if they weren't
identifiable you get a much clearer
vision of how by standards actually
understand what's happening because
they're not aware that the people that
they're working with or speaking with
are themselves targets and so they have
to it's a much clearer perspective on
what they really think right know how
they're acting interesting well we will
look forward to seeing that thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing your work thank you very much
for more information about professor
dean and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again from
their episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you